the individual subpoenaed in the usvi's
epstein-linked case against JP Morgan
okay you got Sergey Brin and Larry Page
you got must you got Michael orvitz he's
the former uh president of Disney uh and
the co-founder of creative arts you got
uh uh Mortimer Zuckerman you got uh
Thomas uh pritzker you got Glenn Durbin
you got Leslie Wexner which we talked
about last time you got John Luke of
Brunell and a few other uh isn't Brunel
dead well it's in your French modeling
Scout who was a closer he was he was
arrested in Paris I believe and uh died
in this jail cell
being a dead person that's when AI is
really Advanced you can do that so so
this comes out but the problem with this
story is the fact that uh Newsweek does
a story a week ago saying Larry Page has
been missing as Google founder faces
Jeffrey Epstein lawsuit the U.S Virgin
Islands that attempting to locate Google
co-founder Larry Page or subpoena him as
part of a lawsuit against JP Morgan
Chase but so far four gospel addresses
have been found invalid the government
brought the civil action against def
defendant JPMorgan Chase Bank as part of
its ongoing effort to protect Public
Safety and to hold accountable those who
facilitated or participate in it
directly or indirectly the trafficking
Enterprise on Jeffrey anyways he keeps
going talking about this so what is if
they're going after these guys there's a
story about page missing there's another
story about Sergey brain going through
what he's going through how much are
they really going to get to the bottom
of this and is this just a nothing
Burger you know I don't know some of the
other cases I think to an extent were
sort of like nothing burgers and some of
these stories about past cases being
unredacted you know a lot of those
redactions it was actually kind of known
what was there this seems a little bit
different because this is the first case
I'm aware of where they're subpoenaing
so many billionaires yeah you know so
that should be kind of an indication
that they at least more than other cases
sort of seem to be interested in getting
more to the bottom of the money aspect
and again this is the JP Morgan case and
as I'm sure you all are aware uh the
Attorney General of the USVI after
filing this case gets fired just a few
days after so of course there's a lot of
speculation that her firing was related
to her filing of this particular case
and you know when it comes to some of
these Tech billionaires I think that's
interesting too because you know in in
my work on Epstein you know there's a
lot to be said about the edge Foundation
Epstein was funding them very
extensively including being like their
only financing source for several years
it was run by publisher John Brockman he
was a science publisher and they had
this annual bill I think billionaires
dinner
they called it which brought Epstein
into contact with a lot of these big
Tech names and a lot of uh you know the
biggest names in Tech including Jeff
Bezos mosque Zuckerberg uh Brynn and
Paige you know have all come up in the
Epstein case even before these subpoenas
um so you know I think that's that's
pretty interesting and another thing too
that I came across recently is that a
lot of these big tech companies have
data centers in New Albany Ohio and the
land on which those data centers sit is
owned by the New Albany company which
Epstein actually set up for Leslie
Wexner and invested in and was a general
partner in that company at the time that
it was planned to court big Tech to that
particular area you know it's
interesting you're saying this we had
Mike Tyson on ethanine he said something
so uh some of these like when you're
when you start doing business you get
invited to parties okay oh sure and when
you go to these parties you're like hey
meet this guy hey meet that guy hey meet
this guy hey meet that guy you're like
oh okay Greg hey meet this guy Jeffrey
Epson oh [__] you're that guy you oh
damn somebody just took a picture here
we go this is what's going to start so
Mike Tyson's at an event in Phoenix and
he says this one guy comes if he can
pull up this picture Rob he says this
one guy comes he starts shaking my hands
and you know he looks very fragile he's
like man I felt so sorry for this guy
and he shook mines his hands were really
small and he was timid I said listen if
anybody does anything to you I got your
back nobody can say anything to you and
uh he says great the next day the feds
come to him and they're like hey we see
this picture with you and him how do you
know this guy he says well did somebody
do something to this guy poor guy was uh
you know I saw him being bullied I want
to make sure he's being he says no we
want to make sure you're okay because he
is he killed eight people and shot 29
people what yeah this is Bill hausner
yeah so there's a picture with Dylan if
he can pull up the picture with him and
Mike Tyson when Mike Tyson said I was at
another fight a Taliban was sitting next
to me and the white supremacist was
sitting next to me and they asked why
would you go to again with a white
supremacist and a Taliban he says I
didn't go to a game with those guys they
just bought tickets right next to me
just so I so how much of this this whole
thing with these names being dropped
it's kind of like Guilty By Association
man I was just I didn't do anything with
these guys I just met him at a party
well it's hard to know uh again because
a lot of people involved in this case
have not been very forthcoming and some
of the names on The subpoena list
there's a lot to say about their ties to
Epstein that has not really found its
way into mainstream reporting but again
uh with some of the cases it could be
just what they say you know I you know I
met them through this guy and that guy
um so you know again without greater
transparency it's hard to know but
allegedly the US Virgin Islands has
access to a very significant amount of
documents from JP Morgan and their
interest in subpoenaing a lot of these
Tech billionaires specifically is that
Epstein was referring them to the bank
and again Epstein's activities with
JPMorgan from what the USVI has said
um it was very clear from JPMorgan
documents that his activity at the bank
was not consistent with any client-based
business and that was supposedly what he
had at the time Epstein and so the money
flow was weird his relationship with
Executives at JP Morgan was weird so why
was he referring people uh to the bank
their speculating that it's related to
some whatever you know funny stuff
Epstein was doing he was trying to bring
in other people would younger girls
well in the case of just Stanley that's
true but again you know and I think we
talked about this last time as I see it
Jeffrey Epstein wasn't just a sexual
blackmail Mastermind he was also very
talented at the world in the world of
Shadow and Offshore Banking so anyone
that wanted to get involved in that
whether it's for things like tax evasion
or all sorts of stuff I mean that
doesn't necessarily involve sexual
blackmail or interest in a sexual
interest in minors right that's but
here's the thing though this is the
problem though with with the Epstein
story because the only thing people
think about when they see a picture with
you and Epstein if they see that online
the first reaction everybody gets they
don't think about tax evasion they don't
think about blackmail they don't think
oh exactly the only thing they think oh
this guy probably hooked up with a 14
year old girl so I understand what
you're saying in that sense okay he got
close to uh JP Morgan Chase and hey they
have this thing where he's brokering
deals and he's bringing money over to
them I can see that I can see how myself
you know I refer God knows how much
business to my advisor that I'm working
with at certain bank and he does my
stuff so when I bank with someone or I
use a technology or I use someone I'm
like go to this guy and they've probably
made a lot of money through those
referrals obviously this is at a larger
scale because he's bringing a billion
dollars half a billion now 300 million
dollars and Jamie Diamond is going to
take those accounts he's not going to
say no to it but the difference between
receiving that referral and the other
aspect of Epstein that's not only
Courier ending that's reputation that's
Legacy that could destroy your in in
your reputation in every way so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]